der durchbruch der hirnforschung
forscher des massachusetts institute of
technology kurz m haben das gehirn von
mäusen manipulierten diese mäuse
erinnerten sich auf befehl an positive
oder negative ereignisse ganz bestimmte
zum einen eröffnen die forschung neue
bahnbrechende therapie möglichkeiten
andererseits sind sie auch eine große
gefahr können wir in zukunft manipuliert
werden
das ist jetzt das thema arbeit die zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
übrigens on tour
manchmal habe ich echt das gefühl dass
wir in einem zeitalter leben in dem
wirklich an allen ecken und enden quasi
minuten tag riesige fortschritte erzielt
werden
aber dazu gibt es ja auch die these dass
die entwicklung durch
vor allem immer schneller fortschreitet
und technische fortschritte oder
forschungsergebnisse nur noch ein paar
tage benötigen um sich zu verbreiten und
unser hirn spielt dabei eine erhebliche
rolle denn da muss das alles verarbeitet
werden es müssen rückschlüsse gezogen
werden erkenntnisse miteinander
verknüpft werden und dass aus unseren
erinnerungen denn wissen besteht aus
erinnerung und diese können die forscher
von m
jetzt manipulieren da kann ich nur mal
wieder wort ausrufen die forscher haben
eine ausgeklügelte technik entwickelt um
erstens erinnerungen ganz gezielt
abzuspeichern und sie dann per
knopfdruck abzurufen
das ist wirklich gespenst was haben die
forscher gemacht zuerst mal haben sie
einen grünen algen gen chr 2 in das
erbgut eingeschleust es kann ein licht
gesteuertes protein produzieren wenn die
nervenzellen jetzt aktiv werden
produzieren sie dieses protein und von
da an können die nervenzellen mit licht
aktiviert werden die grünen also aus
grünalgen gchr 2 hat noch einen
entscheidenden vorteil es kann
abgeschaltet werden
dann wird das protein nicht produziert
das geschieht mit tetracyclin ist das in
der nahrung enthalten passiert genau
diese proteinproduktion nicht die
forscher um den nobelpreisträger sumo
tonica war haben jetzt folgendes gemacht
standardmäßig ist in dem futter der
mäuse tetracyclin beigemischt also es
passiert erstmal nicht hingehören für
den versuch wird die substanz abgesetzt
jetzt ist das car2go
in diesem zustand werden sie mit einem
sehr positiven ereignis oder einem sehr
negativen ereignis konfrontiert zum
beispiel sex mit einer anderen maus oder
elektroschocks danach wird dem futter
wieder tetracyclin beigemischt jetzt
sind die zellen mit dieser erinnerung
über das grünalgen gehen markiert in das
gehirn haben die forscher glasfasern
eingepflanzt über die sie jederzeit die
nervenzellen mit blauem blazer licht
beleuchten können
geschieht das werden die betroffenen
nervenzellen in denen genau diese
erinnerungen abgespeichert ist über das
licht gesteuerte protein aktiviert die
erinnerung wird abgerufen
das heißt sie muss erinnert sich durch
diesen lichtimpuls genau an dieses
ereignis
das heißt dann zum beispiel dass
menschen in depressiven phasen mit
dieser technologie ganz gezielt mit
positiven erinnerungen konfrontiert
werden könnten die negativen folgen
dieser krankheit könnten so zum beispiel
dramatisch verringert werden aber wir
könnten so auch zu komplett willenlosen
wesen werden die totalen manipulierbar
werden da werden dann die schlimmsten
albträume wahr
ja also keine videos mehr zu solchen
anderen themen verpassen
dafür ich mir ein abo aufs auge drücken
und nicht vergessen mir einen auf die
glocke zu geben und was meint ihr sollte
solche forschung verboten werden oder
zumindest unter staatliche kontrolle
gestellt werden diskutiertes in den
kommentaren ansonsten bis dann bleibt
kann